i'm brett baer i'm maria bartoromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday september 8th 2021 i'm lisa
brady democrats plan a busy september on
capitol hill but some republicans say
not so fast they should do nothing until
we do a thorough investigation of
whatever happened in that campus we
speak with florida senator rick scott
i'm dave anthony kovitt has been surging
back to levels at its winter peak
because of a variant even more
contagious than first thought and it's
really almost impossible to avoid it the
the old principles of herd immunity
don't apply to delta delta delta's been
a game changer
and so that's why i'd encourage
everybody who does not have immunity
to go out and get a vaccine dose
and i'm jimmy fella i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
president biden is sounding the alarm
about climate change we're living
through it now we don't have any more
time spending much of tuesday touring
more storm damage from hurricane ida
this time focusing on a more extreme hit
to the northeast than many expected
these waves crashed through the streets
here
testing the aging infrastructure
and taking lives
more lives were taken here
than down in louisiana he met with the
governors of new york and new jersey and
walked through heavily damaged
neighborhoods hugging some homeowners
but also facing a few hecklers
supporters of former president trump
calling president biden despicable for
leaving americans behind in afghanistan
as the white house and state department
pledge to continue diplomatic efforts to
get more people out white house
spokeswoman jensaki we're in touch with
american citizens we're working to get
them out there are four who were able to
depart over land
our secretary of state is in qatar right
now working on a range of options
including getting flights up and
operational ongoing some democrats in
congress also expressing frustration and
concern about the fate of would-be
evacuees connecticut senator richard
blumenthal suggests accountability will
be needed for what he calls inexcusable
bureaucratic red tape that's stranded so
many of our afghan allies
but many democrats including the
president have been turning attention
back to his domestic agenda with storm
damage as the backdrop arguing it's
further evidence that infrastructure
investments are needed including the
three and a half trillion dollar human
infrastructure bill the democrats hope
to push through with a simple majority
possibly as a condition of passing a
smaller package of more traditional
infrastructure plans they should do
nothing until we do a thorough
investigation of whatever happened in
afghanistan 13 americans died because of
the failure of joe biden florida
republican senator rick scott we need to
know exactly how the decisions were made
in congress
we need to stop wasting money the
so-called infrastructure bill had less
than half of it had anything to do with
infrastructure it had at least a quarter
of a trillion dollars of deficit
spending in one bill one bill over 250
billion dollars
increase to our uh our debt
then after that let's remember this is
just a liberal wish list
that is going to raise everybody's taxes
they're going to do everything they can
to fundamentally make people dependent
on government
which is not how this country was
created
have you had any response to either
from either i should say senate majority
leader schumer or house speaker nancy
pelosi to your calls for an
investigation of afghanistan i mean i
know some committees do plan to hold
hearings but have have you heard a
response from from democratic leadership
no pelosi and schumer they wouldn't call
out the by administration because they
know
they know it looked bad for democrats so
no they've not they've not said anything
they are all in and bankrupt in this
country you know their proposal is going
to take us to 45 45 trillion dollars in
debt i mean this is this makes no sense
and causing inflation which is our
poorest family so i'm going to do
everything i can to stop wait for
spending
it's one thing to argue against the big
picture though trillions in new spending
is it harder when the fine print
involves
things that some struggling families
might need like help with child care and
elder care
i'm all in for helping people that need
help absolutely let's pass things that
make sense i got i am a fiduciary for
all the taxpayers of sora and i want to
help people that need help but i'm not
going to go waste their money because
guess what somebody has to pay it back
in the meantime this reckless spending
is doing exactly what they said it was
going to do it's caused inflation look
at gas prices up food prices are up i
mean this divided a democrat plan is
killing our economy and making it
difficult for the poorest families to
get ahead i grew up in in public housing
and a single mom i know it's like to
struggle to get ahead and that's exactly
what they're doing the families like
mine growing up
since the larger bill isn't actually
written yet
is there a chance that the concerns of a
moderate democrat namely west virginia
senator joe manchin
could influence that process enough to
get any republicans on board
i would be shocked i mean let's remember
this three and a half which is really
five and a half trillion which takes her
debt to 45 trillion is led by bernie
sanders and the democrats say they're
only going to tax the rich they can't
tax the rich enough to pay for all the
things that they want to do
so i'll be shocked if they can get one
republican to support this wasteful
spending you know my goal is let's do
good things
but let's do it in a fiscal responsible
manner take infrastructure i spent 85
billion dollars in my eight years as
governor on roads virtues airports and
seaports i believe in it but i also kept
taxes a hundred times and paid off a
third of the state debt you can do all
these things if you want to act
responsibly
just to play devil's advocate for a
minute
the president obviously argues that his
you know economic plans are working and
he says there's been you know seven
straight months of job growth even
though the growth in august wasn't what
he had hoped to see and that these are
investments we have to make you know for
the future are you concerned at all that
any of what he says could at least be
resonating you know with the american
people are you feeling any pressure from
constituents
to get on board with any of these things
what i hear from floridians is they're
scared to death of joe biden and the
democrats spending because they know
it's going to result in tax increases
their
furious over how joe biden handled uh
the withdrawal from afghanistan they're
just furious
um and they're furious oh that that
people will be paid more not to work
than to work
the biden agenda of energy dependency
open borders close schools is not what
americans want
i know you have described the president
as being out to lunch and have said
actually that he should be removed from
office
have you had any support in washington
among republicans at least for that line
of thinking
what i've been clear about is if you
look at his open border policies if you
look at the disaster withdrawal from
afghanistan the 13
members of armed services that should
never have lost their life what i've
said is
the people that are closest to joe biden
his cabinet
have a fiduciary duty to look and say to
themselves is joe biden fit to lead as
commander-in-chief
i saw that you tweeted monday after a
story in the daily mail about the
taliban executing a pregnant police
officer in front of her children and you
wrote that they're showing us they're an
evil murderous gang of terrorists
what jumped out at me was one of the
responses to that tweet
asking you wasn't it president trump who
signed a deal with them are you
disappointed in any way that president
trump did
negotiate and make a withdrawal deal
with the taliban
i think it was clear we should not be in
forever wars i think it's clear that you
know it made sense to leave afghanistan
but no one thought that we would leave
afghanistan where we lost left american
citizens and allies behind in a lurch
i believe that it was time to leave
but you don't leave like this
the president seems to be
you know sticking with his argument that
really everybody was on the same page in
his administration about the way this
was done
for instance the decision to close
bagram first and focus efforts in kabul
what about his argument that his
quote-unquote real choice was either to
get out or send in more troops in other
words it wouldn't have been possible to
just go ahead and stay with the
contingent of 2500
or to
keep bagram open for the evacuation
without surging
troops then
when you're the commander-in-chief which
he is
the buck stops with you you have to make
the decision with all the information
you get from everybody right
he made the decision
that ended up in a disastrous walk
withdrawal from afghanistan where we
lost lives that we shouldn't lost where
we left americans behind it we've never
done before
he
made those calls so we lost 13 people
that should not be dead right now
because of joe biden's foolish actions
what is the mood in washington right now
has it changed
because of this chaotic exit from
afghanistan has that changed the mood on
capitol hill the atmosphere
absolutely people are furious i think
the democrats are embarrassed
of what biden did i think it's going to
be very difficult for him to get much
else done because
you can't trust the guy i mean do you
want to serve a commander-in-chief that
doesn't use the military intelligence
information to keep you safe and that's
what's scaring the living daylights out
of people right now
how does that affect the chance
of getting anything done i mean
whether
you know the public is sitting back and
agreeing with you and saying
you know this is horrible what happened
and it kind of does overshadow the
conversation at least for the moment
how does this affect the chances of
congress being able to do anything
well i've been up there two and a half
years and it's too bad
uh that you can't get things done right
now but if the reason is that the
democrats have have this liberal wish
list that they are just helping on
getting done you could do infrastructure
i'm all in for infrastructure but i'm
not going to go waste money and run
deficits to do it
we ought to be helping the families that
need help right now but we don't have to
spend five half trillion dollars to do
that because the american public was
never on board for these things the way
the public didn't vote to keep our
border open we didn't vote to close our
schools because energy dependent they
didn't vote for leaving afghanistan
where we leave our citizens and our
allies at risk that was never what they
voted for last november so i think it's
going to make it very difficult for the
democrats to get things done because
what they're talking about has never
been something that the american public
bought into
so
just on the
two types of infrastructure packages you
know is it possible
for the smaller one the bipartisan one
to win final passage
if that larger bill ends up stalling
for instance if there isn't you know the
full contingent of democrats willing to
support it in its current form is that
bigger bill gonna end up stopping the
smaller bill or do you think there's a
chance that democrats will let one go
without the other
i'll be surprised nancy pelosi has been
clear that she's not gonna let that
happen but i oppose both of them because
it's a waste of money we should do
infrastructure
roads bridges airports and seaports and
do it in a fiscally responsible manner
we can't that's not what they're doing
so my goal is that neither of these
things pass because it's you're not
spending a lot in a fiduciary manner i
we i represent the citizens of my state
this is not a good use of their money
just to ask one quick follow-up then on
that bipartisan
quote-unquote bipartisan infrastructure
bill since there are some republicans
who support it
what would you like to see in place of
it in place of that smaller bill
let's do a bill
that has
the our federal government investing in
rhodes bridges airports and seaports
okay in places where the federal
government has a responsibility and in
the meantime let's figure out how we can
reduce taxes to grow this economy how we
can reduce regulation to grow this
economy
how how we can stake every dollar of
federal spending and get a return for
the tax breaks their money
florida republican senator rick scott
thank you very very much for your time
thanks lisa have a good day
[Music]
this is jimmy fella with your fox news
commentary coming up
we've now topped 40 million covid cases
across america since the pandemic
started as infections surge again back
to levels not seen since january when it
peaked we've had over a million cases a
week three weeks in a row delta variant
is still spreading rapidly across many
areas of the country dr francis collins
director of the national institutes of
health told fox he is worried that labor
day travel and gatherings could make it
worse and if you're unvaccinated boy
that virus is looking for you and you
don't want to be in a vulnerable place
hospitalizations have also surged again
in many states and deaths have also
spiked nearly 11 000 last week the most
since early march yeah we're not doing
very well particularly in the southeast
and that's because
delta is so contagious it's ripping
through the part of the adult population
that has no immunity dr marty mccary is
a professor at johns hopkins university
and a fox news contributor that segment
of the population which is about 10 to
15 percent of all adults nationwide but
it's 20 to 30 percent of adults in parts
of the southeast where we've got very
low vaccination rates it is ripping very
quickly through those communities and it
may be a bit of a boom and bust we could
see a rapid decline but right now
the death toll is pretty high about 1500
americans are dying each day and they
are adults without natural or vaccinated
immunity so if you're in that group
that's the group right now i would urge
you to go and get at least one dose the
vaccine right away and to try to do it
today people were talking about the
delta variant earlier in the summer but
we know we had uh the fourth of july
came we had cases were low there was
nobody really warning that we would be
back to january levels with infections i
mean did this surprise you
you know i think all of us in public
health who have been talking about covet
have been wrong on a couple things right
we've we've all done our best and nobody
saw india happening not a single expert
had seen
the massive epidemic in india happening
as late as it happened this summer and
then out of that emerged a strain that
we didn't really understand and that was
delta and now we're seeing just how
contagious it is and it's really almost
impossible to avoid it the the old
principles of herd immunity don't apply
to delta delta's been a game changer and
so that's why i'd encourage everybody
who does not have immunity
to go out and get a vaccine dose but
what about those who do have
immunity those who have been vaccinated
there have been breakthrough cases and
we hear them every day so we probably
made a mistake dave when we recommended
the first two doses of the vaccine be
three and four weeks apart and in
general with any vaccine the longer you
space out the doses the better the
immune protection and so i took my
second dose of three months
turns out the studies show that your
immunity is at least three times better
if you did that and so now we're
recognizing if you get uh if that you if
you had two doses close together it kind
of functioned as one dose and you may
need a second dose that's what the data
from israel is suggesting
now israel is
helping the u.s next week they're going
to be working with the fda on boosters
boosters that's next i mean sometime
later this month the pfizer
booster will be available for americans
i guess modern maybe a little bit later
on do you recommend this third dose
for people over age 60 after you're
about six months or eight months out it
does show that it does reduce the rate
of severe illness the thing we really
care about i was not that concerned
about mild breakthrough infections but
in people over 60 we are seeing an
increase in severe illness after you get
past six months and it's probably just
because those first two doses were too
close together people who have been wary
of the vaccine don't believe in it don't
trust it
they use some of this changing
information
to their advantage to say see this stuff
you know they don't know what they're
talking about
and
adding to that confusion is that the
government and our public health leaders
still ignore natural immunity one of the
most inexplicable scientific conclusions
that you could ever have as a public
health official is to look at all this
overwhelming data showing now that
natural immunity is 27 times better than
vaccinated immunity and to conclude oh
we're just going to require those to get
vaccinated anyway that lost a lot of
credibility with public health leaders
what about all those americans who got
the johnson and johnson vaccine are they
going to get a booster
so given the broken fda in the system
that they have we're probably going to
hear about a booster recommendation for
those who got the jnj vaccine a little
bit later and it will probably say hey
you can have a moderna or pfizer you can
mix and match we'll wait to see what the
data truly shows but that's what many of
us believe there's yet another
coronavirus mutation that's getting some
attention the mu variant it's not nearly
as prevalent as delta but biden advisor
dr anthony fauci told cbs face the
nation it has a few a constellation
of mutations that would indicate that it
might evade the protection from certain
antibodies but dr mccary is not worried
about mu
and the reason is that
each new variant in order for it to
compete with the existing variants it
has to be a lot more what we call fit or
contagious and there's no evidence right
now that it's able to penetrate the sort
of market share that delta has so delta
will likely be the dominant variant for
a while and even if mu does populate the
number of infections it does not appear
to have any property where whereby it
evades your body's natural immunity
which is an important factor
okay and so delta is so far is the
strongest one
yeah and that's why we're seeing such a
severe wave right now
sweeping through kentucky north carolina
tennessee much of the southwest is that
it's so much more contagious than we
really thought now you heard initially
it might delta might be say 20 to 30
percent more contagious than 40 to 60.
turns out it's at least twice as
contagious as the prior very contagious
uk strain
all right schools are back in more and
more places now after labor day and the
mask fight varying you know depends on
what state you're in republicans
democrats all this is back and forth and
back and forth we go
masks
how effective are they really
so a big randomized control trial was
just completed
you know i wrote a piece in the wall
street journal suggesting there could be
some downsides to masks and we should
think twice before having mass mandates
in areas where there's no active
outbreak or with kids with disabilities
since then there's been some data and
that randomized control trial found
zero benefit of cloth masks
a real benefit of surgical masks and a
significant benefit for kn 95 masks
which are a little difficult to wear
but that's new data so if you look at
what's happening this virus is so
contagious even in schools where there's
universal masking you're still seeing
massive outbreaks and closures we've got
a thousand schools in the united states
now that have closed since the beginning
of school this year many of them have
had mass mandates i think the conclusion
is
that we cannot rely on these masks to
really
especially cloth masks
to mitigate outbreaks
we did though here for so long that oh
it's not really a factor kids don't
really get sick but hospitalizations
with this new wave
for children have risen quite a bit have
they not
absolutely their 52 million kids in the
us are school-aged children
and upwards of 25 to 27 million of them
have had coven now most asymptomatic and
thank goodness they do develop natural
immunity
but it is one of these
infections right now where you know we
we had we don't have good options
schools don't have good options and
arguing over cloth masks is really not
the right conversation we can't put each
kid in their own private international
space station during the pandemic
they need to interact they need to see
faces of other people and i i don't know
what a good solution is right now for
schools that are wrestling with the
outbreaks yeah because what do you do i
mean you have a lot of kids and you have
a lot of nervousness and then i mean if
you don't shut them then you it spreads
even more potentially i mean it's
difficult decision is it not it's very
challenging i
i will say that
one thing that schools should consider
is to stop quarantining kids that may
have been exposed because that's what's
resulting in a lot of the closures right
now we can't quarantine all of society
because covet is becoming endemic that
means it's everywhere if you test 100
people in america right now
that are asymptomatic probably 10 or 15
are going to test positive even though
it may be a very low viral load and
it cannot make people sick so we need to
recognize that we've got to find a
rhythm to learn to live with covid while
at the same time protecting those that
may have risk factors there's something
else controversial yet another covid
treatment that some who are not
vaccinated have been touting
ivermectin an anti-parasite drug used to
deworm animals the fda has urged people
not to take it saying you're not a horse
or a cow
but there is also a version of ivor
mectin approved for humans and some
suggested it shows promise treating
covid but one doctor who called it a
miracle drug at a senate hearing has
since backed off that claim there was
also misinformation recently that calls
to poison control had soared and
emergency rooms in oklahoma were full of
people who had taken ivermectin so what
does dr mccary think well unfortunately
it's become a symbol of what's wrong
with our national dialogue right now
here's a drug that has been suggested to
have anti-viral properties
some studies have hinted at a slight
benefit it's not going to save your life
i don't think
but there may be a slight benefit from
the potential antiviral properties but
because it's been so demonized after the
hydroxychloroquine wars where people
held on to that form of treatment even
after the studies showed there was no
benefit and that was pretty conclusive
that hydroxychloroquine just does not
have activity it doesn't affect the
virus or its replication
after that we've gotten in this mode now
where anybody who suggests that
ivermectin may be interesting maybe
there should be another study or maybe
it's worth trying because it's a lot
safer than than hydroxychloroquine
they're immediately getting demonized
i'm personally not recommending it at
this time but i will say this dave there
is a false sense of security among those
who have chosen not to get the vaccine
that oh if i get coven ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine and regeneron will
save my life therefore i'm not going to
worry about getting the vaccine and that
is a feeling that is a regret for many
of the 1 500 people who are dying each
day on a ventilator in the united states
and if i could share you know
listeners out there
not being able to breathe in an icu is
the worst feeling patients have ever
described to me and it's not something
you want it's not a situation you ever
want to have to struggle with
and more people who don't have
underlying conditions are getting
themselves in that situation in
hospitals who are younger than it used
to be like a year ago is that correct
that's right and i wish the cdc put out
really good data showing
that it's still hard for this virus to
hurt someone who's entirely healthy and
young and those who are a little older
even
35 45 years of age are at risk of
hospitalization and severe illness and
when you add a risk factor to that
you're introducing a real risk of dying
of covid look if there was a swimming
pool and i told you hey there might be a
shark in that pool and there's a one in
a thousand chance that shark will eat
you he'd probably avoid the swimming
pool
yes i would you know risk appeals to
some people and it's not um it's not
something i'll tell you people feel good
about when they're sick in the hospital
dr marty mccary professor johns hopkins
university always good to talk to you
thanks for joining us
thanks so much dave
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
jimmy fallon
what's on your mind so here's a story
that's making headlines as we head back
to school and work this week dr anthony
fauci says he's keeping an eye on a new
covet variant that could evolve to be
more dangerous but seems okay at the
moment like is it me or is breaking news
actually broken if this new variant
seems okay there's no reason to tell us
about it the breaking news is nothing
happened but something could for one
that's not news that's straight-up
fear-mongering and two we don't need a
new name for every reboot like it's the
fast and the furious think about it even
when it mutates covet is still covered
but make no mistake about it tv hungry
guys like dr fauci know that every new
spin-off is a chance to attract more
eyeballs the only problem is this brazen
scare tactic is becoming really hard to
watch which is why if dr fauci really
wanted to help the country he'd let a
new director take over the movie think
about it doc you've been on tv so much
the last two years they definitely have
you on dancing with the stars or better
yet the masked singer i'm jimmy fallon
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes